JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name is Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
And today, we're going
to talk about the three
flaws in software design
with Max Kanat-Alexander.
Max, why don't you
introduce yourself?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Well, hi, Jeremy.
My name is Max, and I wrote a
book called "Code Simplicity,"
which is published
by O'Reilly Media.
And I now work on
developer productivity
internally at YouTube.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So these three flaws actually
relate to the Law of Change,
and I thought it'd
be good if you
talked a little bit
about that first.
Would you mind just giving us a
little bit of details on that?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
So in my book,
"Code Simplicity,"
I go over the fundamental
laws of software design.
And one of them is
the Law of Change,
which states, "The longer
your program exists,
the more probable it
is that any piece of it
will have to change."
And basically, what
this really means
is that if you want
your system to continue
to be helpful to
people, you're going
to have to keep changing it.
Obviously, software
doesn't change itself.
People change it in
response to demands.
But if you just look at it
objectively as though there
were no people
involved, it just looks
like the software
has to keep changing.
And so that's the law
that you could apply.
You can expect,
basically, that you're
going to have to
keep up with change,
and that the probability
that it will change--
of any piece of it will change
increases as time approaches
infinity, basically.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, why don't we get
into the first flaw,
which is writing code
that isn't needed.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
So the first flaw
in software design--
so I have these
things, and they're
called the "Three Flaws
of Software Design."
And these are the
major categories
of errors that
developers make when
they're trying to
design software.
And the first one is writing
code that isn't needed.
Now, this sounds
like another rule
called "You ain't going to need
it," which is very popular.
It comes from
extreme programming
and from other philosophies.
But the problem that I
have with that phrase
is that's a little bit misnamed,
because it's not really about
whether you're going to need
the code as much as about
whether you know how it
needs to be designed now.
What really matters is
that-- you want really
well-designed code that's
maintainable into the future,
because you want
to be able to cope
with change-- without getting
yourself into a situation
where it's impossible
to deal with that change
or where it's hard
to change the system.
And what you're
writing for is you're
writing for requirements.
And in a way, it's
impossible to really know
what those real
requirements are really
going to be until the
actual situation arrives
that you need to
write the code for.
So I don't say that you
ain't going to need it,
but I just say you
shouldn't write code
that you don't need yet, or you
should wait until you need it.
And the reason is that you run
into all kinds of problems,
right?
So let's say you've
written something that's
going to reverse strings, right?
That's its whole purpose.
That's the only
requirement that you have.
And you decide,
well, you know what?
I like reversing things.
Reversing things is easy.
Let's make it also
able to reverse
all the pixels in an image.
Why you did this-- I don't know.
You just thought maybe I'm
going to need it someday.
I don't need it now, but
maybe I'll need it someday.
The problem is that
that significantly
complicates your code.
It makes your tests
harder to write.
And probably by the
time that you actually
need to reverse
pixels, you'll discover
that you did something
completely different,
like the code that you wrote
didn't perform the right way.
Or it's just not
appropriate-- like you thought
you were going to read
JPEGs, and really you
need to read PNGs.
It's just going to
be the wrong code.
Or it's possible that
it was the right code,
but because it wasn't
used, that by the time
you actually get to
that point, it's rotted
and it no longer
works, and you're
going to have to
change it anyway.
So you're going to
need to redesign it.
And people think, well,
I'm saving myself time
by writing this
before I need it.
But ultimately, you're
not saving yourself time,
because first, you wrote
something that you didn't need,
and then you wrote
something that you did need.
So you actually did basically
the work twice-- or maybe
one and a half times of the
work that you needed to do.
And you're adding complexity.
And in a way, a
lot of what people
are trying to do when
they do this is they're
trying to handle
all the things that
could happen in the future.
But you don't know all the
things that could happen.
And I'm going to get
a little bit more
into that in another
flaw, but this is--
and these flaws are
little bit related.
Sometimes, they
overlap a little bit.
But one of the errors that
people are making when they try
to do this is they're trying
to handle every possible thing,
and they can't.
So there's all kinds of
different ways to do this.
It's very common to see
people write whole classes
or functions that they
don't need, right?
So like maybe they
wrote a whole class
to handle reading pictures
because they wanted
to reverse pixels
in the image, right?
But a lot of the
time, what I see
is just little lines of
code they don't need.
People are doing checks that
they don't need to be doing.
I see this a lot when
I'm doing code reviews.
In fact, one of the
most common comments
that I make in code reviews
is, you don't need that yet,
or, do you need that yet?
Or what's the requirement
that's actually
driving this particular
piece of code?
And it's amazing
how much simpler
you can make code by just
continuously asking this over
and over and over--
is, do you need this?
Or when is this
going to be needed?
Or do you need it now?
And the rule that you can
apply to avoid this situation
or to handle this flaw is
that you don't write code
until you actually
need it, and you
remove any code that
isn't being used.
So the second part is the part
that gets occasionally missed
with the YAGNI, or "You
Ain't Going to Need It"
rule-- is that
once code is dead,
it should just be deleted.
And people think,
well, I don't know.
Maybe I'm going to need that
dead code again in the future,
but that's why we have
version control systems.
If you really need it,
you can pull it back out
of the version control.
Just delete it now.
Many codebases have gotten
into extreme complexity
just by leaving around
tons and tons of dead code.
And now nobody wants to refactor
them, because they think,
oh, look, I'm going to have to
refactor all of these things--
when really, 90% of those
things are dead code
and should have just
been deleted, right?
It's much, much more
approachable to solve
the problems of a
smaller code base.
In addition, the
fact that you don't
have to fix the tests of
code that doesn't exist.
There's all kind of advantages
to code that doesn't exist
or code that isn't written.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: So to
demonstrate this principle,
what we're going to do is we're
going to do an example code
review, and this code review
is a little bit exaggerated.
The code is worse than code
that you might actually see,
and we're going to do a
few more steps than you
might do in a real code review.
But we're going to do it to
demonstrate the principle.
So we have this requirement
for our piece of code.
And it says "Parse a date
string that looks like
'YYYY-MM-DD' and return an
array with three integers.
The first integer is the
year, the second is the month,
and third is the day.
This is internal code
in an application."
It's not a library.
We're not providing this
to the outside world.
And like I said, it's a
little bit of an exaggeration.
So let's look at this over here.
So the code that the
developer writes and submits
to you, the code
reviewer, is this mess.
So up here, it's got
three constants that
say this is the year, this is
the month, this is the day.
It's preparing to parse
a year string, a month
string, and a day string.
It has comments for
every line of code,
and you can see it's going
through-- if you're not
familiar with Python, enumerate
means give me both the index
and the item from an array.
In this case, we're going
through the characters
in a string.
And it checks, OK, if we're
in the first four characters,
this must be the year.
And then, oh, is
it a valid integer?
We're going to
check that we have
a hyphen in the right
place, next two characters
have to be the month.
If they're not digits, then
we should raise an exception.
OK, then we're going to figure
out that this is the month.
OK, we've validated that
all these things are right,
that the format is right.
Oh, and if the string is too
long, we raise an exception.
Now we check if the whole year
is an integer, and then, well,
if that's-- we throw
another exception.
And then finally, we create
an integer for the year.
this return value array,
and then we set each thing
in the return value array
and then we return
the return value.
OK, so this is obviously
a disaster, right?
And a lot of the
time in code review
when you're presented
with a disaster,
it's hard to know
where to begin.
You just-- frustrating.
You say, well, just go away and
don't ever write code again.
But that doesn't
help you, and it
doesn't educate the person
whose code you're reviewing.
So I want to try to take some
tack, some direction that we
can do with this.
So the first thing I'm
going to tell the developer
is, the first thing you
don't need in this file
is all of the comments.
I didn't need any
of those comments.
I can read code.
You told me what every
line of code was doing.
Surprisingly, the code became
considerably more readable.
It's not good.
But if you look through
it, it's much shorter.
We lost about 20 lines.
It's about 55 lines now.
The first one was 71 lines.
And you can actually kind of
start to tell what's going on.
So now, you can start
to see the next problem.
And the next problem
is we know actually--
so we did some research.
We investigated this.
And we said your input doesn't
include any years, months,
or days that are
out of range-- which
means there's no 13 for
the month, there's no 32
for the day, and
there's no negative 1
for the year or
anything like that.
And what this represents is
a really important principle,
which is that it's really
important to find out
what your actual
requirements are.
A lot of the time, developers
assume requirements,
and then they write code for
those assumed requirements.
And I see this a lot.
In fact, one of the
most important things
that I feel like I do
when I'm writing code
is ask a lot of
questions to people.
Go and say, well, what does
this actually need to do,
before I go and write it.
And I find that that allows
for a lot of simplification
that I didn't otherwise expect.
Because sometimes
if you don't know,
you just assume
that, for example,
there's a lot of inputs
that you could get.
But when you actually
go and find out,
you discover there's
actually very few inputs
that you could get, and your
code can be much, much simpler
than you thought.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
I thought that was
really good in the book
when I was reading it.
I think I always
tend to over-think
like, I've got to
check all the stuff.
But then I was like,
oh, that's a good point.
You should really go back and
ask, is the input coming in?
What is the range-- do I
have to check everything?
And most times, I
think, you don't, so--
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, and there's
actually a blog
post that I wrote
called "The Secret
of Fast Programming:
Stop Thinking," which
goes over all of the ways
that you can get
information without having
to sit there and think
about it, and also about
how that improves productivity.
And this is really just a
facet of that, a piece of that,
or an aspect of that-- which is
that the information that you
need for development is very
frequently not in your mind.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, OK.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Right?
And so inventing it, or
using your mind to get it
is the wrong tool.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, yeah.
OK, that makes sense.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
Go back to the code here.
We also note that, if you
remember from the original,
he checks that every
individual digit is a digit,
and then he checks that
the result of all those
was a digit.
It's not like-- you
don't need to do that.
That's not necessary.
And so we're getting down to
almost one page of code now.
It's starting to
become readable.
I can almost tell
what's happening here.
We're now at 41 lines.
And so our next comment of
things-- and all are doing
is applying this exact
principle over and over.
All we're doing is just
continuously saying,
do you need this?
Do you need this?
Or telling him, you
don't need this.
You don't need this.
So now we can say
that it's always
integers in the year,
month, or day positions.
So you don't have to check
that they're integers.
You don't have to validate
their integer-ness.
And now it's becoming
more reasonable.
And your input always has
hyphens in the hyphen position.
There's never any
other character.
We're kind of getting closer
to something that the developer
should realize at this point,
but maybe they haven't.
And I'll tell you what that is
when we get to the last point.
And now it's 29
lines and relatively
straightforward-- getting
even more straightforward.
And also, so now we're
going to say you never
have strings that are too long.
So there's never a string that's
longer than a date should be.
And also, this is
Python, so if you
want to return three
values in an array,
you can actually just do this
where you just write a triple.
You don't need to
create an array
and then set all of its values.
So now, hopefully the
developers thought about this,
but maybe they haven't-- that
what we're telling them is
your input is
always well-formed.
So you don't actually need to
do any validation whatsoever.
All of your validation
is unnecessary.
It's very possible that
in a real code review,
this would have been
our first comment.
But we might not have
been able to see that,
because there was so much
complexity that you might have
been able to see
like, oh, what are
all the things we can eliminate.
You might have needed to go
through this iterative process
with the review in
order to actually
be able to figure that out.
But the ultimate thing that
we're saying-- your input
is always well-formed.
You don't need to have a loop.
You don't need to
have a state machine.
None of this is necessary.
You can write this whole
function in two lines of code,
and here they are.
JEREMY WALKER: Perfect.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: So
that is our code review.
And that's an example
of how you would
apply this law in your
actual development.
So that completes our
discussion of the first flaw
in software design.
Let's go to any questions.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, so I
actually had one question.
I always like
real-world examples,
and you gave a pretty good one
in the book, which I thought
would be good to cover here.
So can you talk about that?
It was with the
lists, I believe.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Yeah, so this
is actually
something that I did.
So I worked on a
project called Bugzilla,
which is a bug tracking system.
And so there's drop
down fields in Bugzilla.
You can choose what the
severity of a bug is
or what the priority
of a bug is.
And I was like, well,
you know, there's
all kinds of things
we want to do.
We want to allow
people to rename them.
And right now, we're
referring to all of them
by its strings in the database.
We're referring
to other strings.
So I was like,
let's-- oh, no, no.
Oh, right.
I remember what it was.
It wasn't that we
wanted to rename them.
It was they wanted to be able
turn them off or turn them on,
right?
So I added all this
code, particularly
at the database layer.
I added database fields to say,
is this field active-- right?
But I didn't actually
implement it.
I just threw in a
bunch of database stuff
because I thought,
well, tomorrow, I'm
going to write the change that
enables it in the front-end.
And then of course, tomorrow,
something crazy came up,
and I had to work on this,
and I totally forgot about,
and I had a million
more important things.
And then three years later,
somebody comes along, and is
like, what is this?
This doesn't make any sense.
And also, in those
intervening three years,
we must have had at
least 10 bugs filed
by people who had manually gone
in and changed their database.
And some of the code had checked
if the field value was active,
and some of the
code hadn't checked
if the field value was active.
And so it caused
incredibly confusing bugs.
People would report
these weird bugs
like-- it shows up in the search
interface but not on the bugs
or it shows up on
the bug editing page
but not on the
bug creation page.
And finally, when somebody
did implement the ability
to disable values,
they actually had
to do it a completely
different way, because I
had named the database
fields in a way that
was inconsistent with
our later convention.
So they had to rename all
the fields in the database,
and then write a completely
different implementation
because our framework
had completely
changed in those
intervening three years.
And it ended up being a
total waste of time, which
did nothing but cause
bugs and confusion
for anybody who ever went in
and tried to do this manually.
Because Bugzilla
in particular was
a product where everybody
wanted to customize it.
People understood
database design,
and the they would make
their own changes to it.
And so they would
look at the tables,
and they would actually see
this and they would actually
try to do that.
And it just caused
nothing but trouble,
and it did nobody
any good, basically.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I thought
that was a great example.
Well, great.
Well hopefully, that gives
you a little bit of a taste.
That covers the first of the
three flaws in our series.
Please join us for
the next video.